What would you do if you happen to have a client in an area where search volume for any keyword is 10?
Only way I was able to make it work was by expanding radius to 30 miles around the city.
Do you just focus on surrounding area service pages? What is the best strategy to rank to
get enough volume? That's going to be a tough one, especially because I don't even know,
like 10 is going to be extremely tough. Biggest thing you're going to have to do is set expectations.
And then I assume because there's only 10 that the city size is not that big,
which means it's probably not super competitive unless it's carpet cleaning,
which means you should be able to build a website in the main city and service page, or sorry,
location pages in the surrounding cities and rank those fairly easily. So picture it like this,
right? Let's use a city like Nashville because it's easy to explain. Although this wouldn't be
the case because these surrounding cities are actually bigger, but just so you guys can picture
this. Let's say that Nashville only had a search volume of 10 for carpet cleaning,
which would never be the case, but let's just say it. Or we can even say something else. We
could say excavation, which again, wouldn't be the case. Nashville is huge, but let's say it did.
And you're like, crap, I need to figure out how to get more leads in some of these outskirts in
Clarksville and excuse me, Murfreesboro in Lebanon and whatever the case is, right?
What's some of the other cities? Why am I having a brain funk here? What's the other one after?
Anyway, it doesn't matter. What I would tell you is that assuming that this city that you're
targeting only has 10 volume, I'm guessing it's not a huge city. And I'm guessing the outskirts
cities are not big either, which means they're probably not competitive. So what I would do is
I would build the site. Let's say it's tree service Nashville. Maybe we should use it as a
different example. Let's use a different example actually, because everyone's going to go and
think this is the case. Let's use something everyone would know. I'll use Salt Lake City.
You guys won't know what that is, but I can explain it to you. So Salt Lake City,
I'm going to pull up a map here to explain this. And you guys can do the same thing.
Type in Salt Lake City and go to a map. And I'm going to show you what I mean.
So if I was trying to do this in Salt Lake City, what I would do is, and let's say Salt Lake City
was only 10, right? The volume was 10 in whatever it is, excavation. What I would do is I'd build
the main website as saltlakecityexcavation.com, whatever. And I would focus tons and tons and
tons of energy on ranking there. Now, what I'd also say, Shane, is that if this deal is not a
guaranteed done deal, I wouldn't mess with it, right? Is this a deal you're pre-selling or
somebody came to you? Because if somebody's coming to me, it's one thing, but I'm not going to go
into a city on my own dime that's only got 10. But let's say somebody did come to you.
What I would do is I'd build the website in that main city that has a search volume of 10.
And then I would have location pages. So it'd be saltlakecityexcavation.com forward slash
bountiful. And in bountiful, I would treat Salt Lake City's excavation.com forward slash bountiful.
That URL, I would treat it as its own homepage, right? That would be like a homepage because you
are going to be ranking that page against everyone else in bountiful that's doing excavation.
Then I'd have another location page would be saltlakecityexcavation.com forward slash west
valley. Now, for those of you that know Salt Lake West Valley is not somewhere I'd build a website
in because it's just not the spot. But just to give you an example, and I mean that because
it's kind of a sketchy city, west valley, you know, west valley, saltlakecityexcavation.com
forward slash west valley. And I have another one that was saltlakecityexcavation.com forward
slash, let me zoom in a little more, we could say West Jordan, Salt Lake City, you know, and
I'm looking at all these little pockets and I'm trying to do research the best that I can. You
could have one forward slash Kearns forward slash Murray forward slash Woods Cross forward slash
North Salt Lake. That's how I would do it to try and, you know, get as many leads as possible. But
again, I wouldn't even go into the city knowing there's only 10 volume unless somebody came to me
and was like, hey, I really need leads in the city because if somebody came to me and said they
just need leads, I would just say, well, what other areas do you cover besides this city?
Because it doesn't have that much volume. I'll do it for you. But can you do other cities? Can
we look at something else? That's what I would do. Okay. Hopefully that made sense. Sorry,
I get a little long-winded trying to explain that. I want you guys to understand where my
thought process is, but that's what I would do. And that's from experience.